wir bei bild berichten jetzt seit wochen
über die dramatische lage in den
flutgebieten in den immer noch über die
immer noch dramatische lage in den
flutgebieten muss man sagen denn dort
hat sich politisch viel zu wenig getan
von all den hilfen die versprochen
worden ist viel zu wenig angekommen von
alldem wir werden euch nicht vergessen
ist viel zu wenig umgesetzt worden
hiervon sind da vor ort auf teilweise
desolate zustände gestoßen und haben es
uns selbst wegen zur aufgabe gemacht das
einzuhalten was von der politik so oft
versprochen worden ist nämlich die
menschen vor ort nicht zu vergessen
weiter zu berichten über ihr schicksal
weiter zu berichten über das was dort
nicht funktioniert denn genau das ist
die aufgabe von journalismus zu
hinterfragen was das bedeutet was
politiker gesagt haben wenn sie nach
ihrem kurzen besuch in den flutgebieten
wieder abgereist sind unter anderem die
bundeskanzlerin ein wir werden euch
nicht vergessen die menschen vor ort
sagen uns etwas anderes wir haben dort
ein büro eingerichtet wir sind jeden tag
dort wir sprechen jeden tag dort mit den
menschen und das gefällt nicht jedem
besonders nicht unseren freunden vom
öffentlich rechtlichen fernsehen die es
sich ein in vielen sendungen zur aufgabe
gemacht haben besonders regierungstreu
zu berichten besonders hart gegen jene
vorzugehen die regierungspolitik
kritisch beleuchten und dazu gehören wir
und gestern da sehen wir es jetzt
eingeblendet er hat uns mal wieder eine
anfrage von unseren freunden von zap
erreicht ab für alle die es nicht gucken
viele gucken ziemlich nicht ist ein
medien magazin des ndr was ich besonders
gerne immer wieder kritisch mit bild
-bericht beschäftigt und was hatten wir
da gestern für eine anfrage bekommen
tapfer also jetzt auch in den
flutgebieten um darüber zu berichten wie
wir berichten und natürlich mag keine
regierungskritischen journalismus
natürlich möchte man bei tap lieber das
gefeiert wird was die regierung sagt das
für richtig erklärt wird was die
regierung sagt wie es viel zu oft im
öffentlich rechtlichen fernsehen
passiert und deswegen bekommen wir von
sub gestern eine anfrage in der es heißt
in gesprächen mit den menschen kamen
aber kritik an der bild wie folgt da
sagt man nicht etwa konkret wer die
quelle für diese kritik ist sondern die
menschen sagen dass einfach wenn man vor
ort war und mit der kamera gedreht hat
könnte man doch einfach sagen wer diese
menschen sind dann könnte man die
vorwürfe doch einfach konkretisieren
passiert hier aber nicht es wird mal
wieder mit diesen propagandistischen
methoden mit anonymer kritik von den
menschen im aartal
gearbeitet und angeblich sagen die krise
menschen folgendes wenn man sich nur die
überschriften anschaut dann geht es
immer darum dass irgendwelche stellen
versagt hätten dann bedienen sie also
wir ja genau ein narrativ von achtung
rechten kreisen von querdenkern und da
muss ich sagen dann ist vielleicht auch
das privatwirtschaftliche unternehmen
bild einfach nur daran interessiert eine
gewisse klientel als kern klientel zu
erhalten aha sobald also kritisch
berichtet wird darüber über einen ort an
dem das öffentlich-rechtliche versagen
nicht hätte größer sein können wir
erinnern uns bei der flut die flut ist
dem 80 rechtlichen fernsehen erst mal
gar nicht aufgefallen bild war zuerst da
als wir da waren war der wdr noch längst
nicht da in der flut nacht war der wdr
noch längst nicht da aber dass wir jetzt
kritisch berichten darüber kann
natürlich wieder nur das narrativ von
rechten kreisen und von querdenkern
bedienen und natürlich tun wir erst mal
wieder nur weil wir uns diese rechten
kreise und querdenker als klientel
erhalten wollen und als kunden erhalten
wollen niemand kommt herauf vielleicht
einfach mal zu sagen das ist dort
missstände gibt auf die idee kommt man
gar nicht bei unseren
öffentlich-rechtlichen freundin
kritische berichterstattung ganz
eindeutig muss etwas mit rechten kreisen
und querdenken und das ist ein so großes
gesellschaftliches problem und deswegen
wenden sich menschen auch so oft vom
öffentlich rechtlichen fernsehen ab denn
sobald sie eine kritische meinung haben
sobald sie regierungskritisch sind
sobald sie sich kritisch darüber äußern
da ist die politik sich nicht um sie
kümmert nachdem ihr leben vernichtet und
ausgelöscht und weggespült worden ist
werden sie im öffentlich rechtlichen
fernsehen als rechte und als querdenker
die familie das schlimme an dem es so
gerade bericht als finanz finde ich gar
nicht mal unbedingt dass es einen
angriff gegen bild oder unsere berichte
dass menschen durch einen angriff auf
die menschen und ich muss sagen einem
stundenlangen damals bei der flut
berichtet und ich habe gesehen wie es
den menschen dort geht und wir berichten
jetzt weiter mit unserem flut büro in
der eifel stube im übrigen dass wir hier
auch einmal erwähnen wenn sie betroffen
sind das ist in der eifel stube in bad
neuenahr da sind wir für sie da kommen
die menschen hin immer noch mit
problemen ganz zentralen problemen wie
keinen strom jetzt wo die temperaturen
keine heizung wieder kälter werden und
man verhöhnt damit diese menschen die
sich darüber beschweren dass es eben
nicht funktioniert dass sie in großer
not sind und stellt sie in eine ecke und
das ist auch umfasst wer sich kritisch
äußert über das grauen über das
schicksal was ihm passiert ist und die
untätigkeit der politik wird hier vom
öffentlich rechtlichen fernsehen mal
wieder zum rechten querdenker diffamiert
abgestempelt das ist etwas was wir schon
so häufig erlebt haben es ist etwas was
glaube ich in der flüchtlingskrise
losging menschen mit kritischer meinung
waren dann rechts waren der begriff
querdenker ist jetzt neu menschen die in
der korona zeit sich fragen gestellt
haben waren flächendeckend sofort alle
querdenker aber das ist tatsächlich eine
neue stufe menschen die alles verloren
haben werden jetzt anonym als zeugen
herbeigeführt ohne dass man das konkret
sagt um andere menschen die kritische
die alles verloren haben als rechte
querdenker zu diffamieren ich fand das
ist etwas was man einmal transparent
machen sollte so wird da gearbeitet und
so wird diffamiert sobald jemand sich
kritisch über ja wirklich teilweise
verheerenden der arbeit von landes- und
bundesregierung äußert
[Musik]